[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sion par
les sports le quatrième épisode de cette
saison sur tb 78 ce mercredi 4 novembre
jour de cet enregistrement on le connaît
a toujours pas le nouveau président des
états unis la france vient d'entamer son
deuxième confinement mais rassurez-vous
si le monde bouge la thématique de cette
émission ne change pas elle est encore
et toujours consacré à l'actualité
sportive locale et nos chroniqueurs sont
avec nous pour décortiquer cette
actualité
vu les conditions à saly taire certains
sont en plateau et d'autres via écran
interposé présentation musique c'est un
grand sportif il a été à champion du
monde master de cyclisme il a été
champion de roller il commence
maintenant
le volley ball on a de la chance de
l'avoir sur ce plateau yann jarrier le
capitaine est avec nous bonsoir michael
je suis toujours champion du monde
champion du mans oui vous avez tous voté
non vérifié je suis champion en titre
avec le confinement
je prends et je prends un nombre plus ou
moins un an
alors passez de l'autre côté à musique
et lui aussi est avec nous en plateau
c'est sa quatrième participation à cette
émission les journalistes chez tva 78 il
se nourrit de football italien il vibre
football italien c'est une encyclopédie
vivante c'est grégory canale est avec
nous - jean-michel quand allez-vous bas
ça va très bien on va parler de sport ce
qu'on n'a plus l'occasion de pratiquer
en ce moment donc on est content quand
même de parler on parle de sport pas
italien par contre 1 l'omnisports
yvelinois bien sûr sport mais un peu
plus on va naviguer aussi aujourd'hui
n'en dit pas trop nous serons donc 3 en
plateau les autres sont avec nous via
écran interposé à cause du contexte
sanitaire je le précisais a précédemment
musique
il est un grand fan de saint-etienne et
de
football il pratique également le
handball et le basket bref c'est un
grand sportif mais il est à l'arrêt en
ce moment avec le confinement stéphane
de visite avec nous pendant une heure
stéphane comment allez vous quand
allez-vous stéphane pourtant qui est un
problème de son nom est ce que vous
entendez nom du mal à entendre d'accord
bon est-ce que ça va là ça va oui est ce
que vous allez bien ça va ça va ça va on
vit avec le confinement c'est un peu dur
quant à saint-etienne ou continue
doucement et sûrement descente en enfer
donc tout va bien alors lui aussi est
que connecter via écran interposé
musique c'est un mythe c'est un cap
c'est une péninsule une légende de cette
émission il est revigoré par des
vacances dans le sud de la france il va
se donner à fond le gladiateur pire
chevallier est avec nous pendant une
heure pierre comment allez vous je n'ai
pas du tout entendu ce que vous avez dit
michael avait la musique plein tube dans
l'est dans les oreilles je n'ai pas
entendu le lancement est ce que vous
êtes revigoré par vos vacances oui des
vacances des vacances en corse
absolument magnifique où il a fait très
beau on a profité des derniers rayons du
soleil et des derniers instants de
liberté vous à irvine et votre bronzage
enchères mais pour quelques temps vous
avez peaufiner votre bronzage
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de cyclisme le tour de
france passera par les yvelines en 2021
tous les détails dans ce talk coup de
projecteur également sur le départ de
laurent fournier de l'équipe de football
de poissy le coach a été remercié par
ses dirigeants mais avant de développer
ces thèmes
on va parler du coc vie de 19 et du
confinement
[Musique]
bis repetita pour le sport amateur ce
nouveau confinement va une nouvelle fois
à perturber la pratique sportive pendant
au minimum quatre semaines pour les
sports en intérieur la fédération
française de handball avait été l'une
des premières à arrêter la compétition -
au moins jusqu'en décembre
tout comme la fédération française de
volley-ball pour le basket les
compétitions stop également jusqu'à
cette période mais les dirigeants
s'attendent à un redémarrage des
compétitions pour le début d'année
prochaine on écoute une réaction venue
du monde du basket
la fédération de basket à au moins dit
qu' il y aurait une inertie de quinze
jours quand les rencontres pourrait
reprendre pour permettre aux équipes de
se ré entraîner les de manière à assurer
une certaine équité sportive et surtout
une intégrité physique de la part de
tous les sportifs qu'ils laquelle que
quel que soit le niveau auquel ils
jouent pour le football mercredi dernier
la fédération française a annoncé la
suspension des compétitions de ligue 2
districts des championnats nationaux du
national 2 et 3 ainsi que de la coupe de
france et des championnats nationaux aux
jeunes cette mesure s'appliquera au
minimum jusqu'au 1er décembre
un casse tête en vue pour les instances
ça pose la question on n'a pas encore
pris de décision mais on va y réfléchir
maintenant c'est les coupes
parce qu'on a les championnats d'à côté
mais les coupes des yvelines d'autre
part on avait déjà les coupes les coupes
futsal
qui était calé comme futsal seniors qui
avait dont il avait été décidé qu'elle
n'aurait pas lieu maintenant la question
va se poser pour l'ensemble des coupes
de toutes les catégories les seniors les
u18 les u16 du14 les féminines et c'est
parce qu'il va falloir sans doute se
consacrer uniquement au championnat
le rugby amateur se mettent également
pause jusqu'à à début janvier au minimum
la fédération a également annoncé
l'annulation des phases finales pour
permettre aux championnats de se jouer
jusqu'au bout pour éviter la saison
blanche la question sur cette thématique
est ce que c'est une catastrophe pour le
sport y vinoy vous voter non pour vous
il ya dujarrier oui stéphane où vous
êtes comment c'est une catastrophe
on fait un petit duel peut être entre
vos pierre et eliane vous êtes indécis
bout mais une paralysie vaut commencer
une catastrophe aujourd'hui je trouve
que le mot et le mot est un peu fort
mais
il va il va y avoir des grosses
perturbations en effet déjà juste quand
j'entends que le au basket on va
permettre au club de pouvoir s'entraîner
pendant quinze jours reprendre les
compétitions mois éviter les blessures
prix pour la paix mais quinze jours de
préparation c'est ridicule dans la vie
d'un athlète
donc soit il est tout le monde arrive à
rester sérieux et à utiliser
tranquillement pour pouvoir travailler
très sérieusement et ce sera pour moi je
pense indispensable et les clubs qui
s'en sortiront mieux seront ce seront
les clubs dont les joues les les dix
adhérents auront été les plus les plus
sérieux pendant cette période de
confinement parce que je suis désolé
mais quinze jours d'entraînement pour un
club amateur ça fait quatre
entraînements en quatre entraînements on
est prêt en rien pour pouvoir faire un
match et un match quel qu'il soit et il
y aura les vacances aussi
entre temps il va y avoir les vacances
de noël qui vont venir juste derrière
adore ce sera ce sera en janvier
normalement c'est prévu mais reprise
normalement début décembre
quinze jours de boulot bien sûr avec
notamment le travail et deux semaines
ensuite de vacances et retour en janvier
pour la compétition non mais cessez donc
voilà c'est aujourd'hui c'est un
discours que les que les coaches doivent
avoir pour avec leur avec leur carte
athlètes pour leur dire les gars il faut
être attaqué vous vous entraînez de
manière très très importante très très
rigoureuse voilà parce que la reprise va
être très très difficile
et si vous êtes sérieux et bien on fera
la différence au moment de au moment de
la reprise des max c'est vraiment un
passage qui est très difficile et alors
après il ya des sports où en effet c'est
possible mais je vois des russes pensent
à bobby manno rugbyman ou enfin le
toucher de ballon c'est quelque chose
qui est hyper important et on qu'un jour
vous avez rien fait il faut souvent
arrêtés donc oui oui non alors
catastrophique
non parce que il reste du temps derrière
mais très compliqué à gérer oui ça
c'est pour ça que je dis je suis je suis
indécis parce que en effet c'est
possible mais si on est rigolo c'est
possible sion doerig le synthétise que
vous exactement
pierre chevallier même même hésitation
que yann sur le sur le sujet qui a
catastrophique était un peu un peu fort
4 de toute façon c'est un contexte qui
s'imposent à nous
totalement inédit là où j'ai insisterait
c'est sûr c'est sur plusieurs sur deux
points au moins le premier c'est que
c'est déjà le deuxième confinement on a
déjà on a déjà débattu sur le premier
avec ses conséquences notamment sur le
sur les saisons précédentes sur la
saison 2019-2020 la sar mais la saison
2020-2021 entre parenthèses et le
deuxième point c'est sur le côté je
pense
écoutez sportive il ya de parler d'un
parti préparation physique c'est à dire
ceux qui auront les moyens et qui ont
l'occasion de maintenir une condition
physique notamment pour les sports de
contact et pour les sports qui nécessite
justement des athlétes ise et de pouvoir
être compétitif pour pouvoir pour voir
poursuivre les combles des compétitions
pour le rugby que je connais bien on a
on a en fait deux dates qui ont été
annoncées la première c'est comme comme
pour le comme pour tout le monde la
suspension des activités et le
confinement jusqu'au 1er décembre
ça c'est la première étape mais déjà il
ya la deuxième date qui a été annoncé la
suspension des sus des compétitions
amateurs jusqu'au 10 janvier 2021 donc
déjà on sait qu'on aura pas de matches
d'ici là on aura peut-être la
possibilité de se ré entraîner à partir
du 1er décembre si jamais le deuxième
confinement élevé mais rien n'est moins
sûr et puis derrière en fait là là où
c'est là où c'est compliqué le joint
aussi yann ça ou ça va être compliqué à
celle qu une question d'agenda et
calendrier il ya eu déjà beaucoup de
reports en cette première partie de
saison
les phases finales du rugby qui sont si
chères au rugby amateur sont déjà d'ores
et déjà annulé pour pouvoir finir les
matches de poule
à partir du moment où on pourra
recommencer à jouer des matches
mais ça va être ça va être un casse tête
incroyable pour pouvoir retrouver des
dates et surtout pour pouvoir être
équitable au niveau sportif avec des
degrés de préparation qui vont être
évidemment différent seulement les
crèmes finalement vous êtes assez
d'accord tous les deux vous allez partir
en vacances ensemble en corse peut être
stéphane devise est je vous passe est
apparu ensuite grégory c'est vrai que ma
préparation individuelle a son
importance mais moi je pratique le
basket le rugby fauteuil l'europe
auteuil et on a besoin de ce contact
avec le ballon on a besoin de travailler
ddd schéma tout le temps encore et
encore et là c'est sûr que quand on va
reprendre les matches vont être
vachement en difficulté ça va pas être
simple non pour ma part ça va pas être
le top du top
grégory pour vite que moi je disais oui
catastrophique alors bien sûr moins
catastrophique que l'épidémie qui qui
secoue en ce moment le monde entier
catastrophique parce que voilà c'est on
est pire le rappelait à 2 confinant
quelques mois la fin de saison dernière
qui a été complètement tronquée là c'est
le début de saison donc c'est quand même
aussi quelque chose de plus particulier
où on commence à avoir des automatismes
notamment dans les équipes collective au
football ont commencé à engranger des
automatismes qui vont être déjà mise à
mal voilà ses premiers automatismes
qu'on avait au bout de deux mois final
beaucoup de moi finalement donc c'est
cette première partie de saison qui est
tronqué faut pas oublier aussi que par
rapport au premier confinement on
pouvait aller couvrir le soir suivez
jour assez assez tard là on est en plein
hiver donc aller courir la nuit en forêt
ou autour de chez nous c'est déjà aussi
un peu plus compliqué puisque la
pratique sportive individuelle reste
autorisée dans dans un rayon d'un
kilomètre et dans la limite d'une heure
donc moi je pense ça va être compliqué
aussi de synthétiser catastrophique du
point de vue sportif catastrophique du
point de vue social voilà je le
rappelais la dernière fois le sport
c'est aussi à une vocation sociale le
club de sport c'est une deuxième famille
donc catastrophique sur le plan sportif
et sur le
le plan aussi sociale c'est surtout un
cac cède finalement si on comprend bien
au niveau des compétitions surtout selon
vous y allez casse tête
un casse tête au niveau de l'oreille de
l'appellation bah oui un casse-tête pour
l'organisation des oui c'est ce que
c'est suffisamment ces squelettes et
isation les athlètes ça peut ça peut ça
peut se faire un peu n'importe quand
chez soi ou la cotisation oui bien sûr à
condition d'avoir un peu de matos je
suis désolé un rugbyman qui est dans la
mêlée il faut un peu de poids quand même
pour pour travailler le physique il faut
nous impasse politique bien sûr mais il
faut un peu de poids pour pouvoir
travailler juste la force quand vous
faites du camp nou fait de la course à
pied à la rigueur vous pouvez vous dire
je vais faire une phase de fitness
renforcement musculaire travail de
préparation physique générale il ya
plein de choses qui sont qui sont
possibles à faire mais quand il faut
mettre du poids quand on a besoin de
faire du gain de force du gam puissance
ça se fait pas avec ça se fait pas en
prenant deux bouteilles d'un médecin que
dans chaque main non c'est pas ça
il ya un moment où par exemple moi quand
je faisais des squats pour pour le vélo
on était arrivé à la santé avec des
répétitions à 140 kg 140 kilos vous
passez à la maison donc en effet vous
pouvez pas le travail et de la même
manière donc enfin vous pouvez pas de
travailler du tout et ça c'est des
choses qui peuvent se faire que l'on
tond salle de concert de musique donc il
ya des choses qui sont oui possible pour
travailler le cardio pour travailler du
réflexe pour il ya des choses qui sont
possibles maintenant on te pas tous
travailler et quand on parle de
préparation pour pouvoir faire un match
et dans des sports de contact
c'est de la force dont on parle et je
suis désolé quinze jours ce sera pas
suffisant pour pouvoir éviter les
accidents
justement où il peut y avoir des
accidents à pierre chevalier oui en
haillons bas en rugby depuis début de la
saison notamment pas dessus passion mais
c'est gros c'est qu'on ne serait ce pas
la reprise du premier après premier
confinement pas la reprise tant mieux
pas déplorer du moins mais mais comme
comme on le rappeler tous en fête le
côté athlétique à sion c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut faire on va dire en
surface chez soi mais pas forcément en
profondeur avec le spécifique et surtout
pas le jeu collectif du rugby par
exemple
c'est pour ça qu'on a pris les décisions
par exemple à versailles de faire des
entraînements a lancé c'est là où on
pousse vraiment le moderne jusqu'au bout
et le virtuel jusqu'au bout ce sont des
entraînements physiques par par
visioconférence je vous dis c'est très
très très drôle à savoir faire ou alors
c'est très très dur à réaliser mais en
tout cas on est on essaie de maintenir
les joueurs en forme physique pour
pouvoir reprendre dès qu'on pourra le
décompose
mais pour l'instant pas de danger ou pas
d'accident au doute et je voulais vous
entendre pierre chevalier également sur
ces phases finales qui ont été supprimés
on voit aussi en plus ils ont supprimé
la coupe des yvelines
finalement c'est un peu l'essence du
rugby qu'est qui s'en va cette saison a
complètement commencé lorsqu on en a
parlé la dernière fois il y avait on
avait déjà évoqué le problème de
calendrier avec déjà des premières
journées où il y avait beaucoup de
beaucoup de matches reportés et ont été
reportés déjà en février et en février
honda et à partir de février ont
commencé à se dire il va y avoir un
embouteillage
il y aura plus de dates disponibles là
la fédé a appris donc ma décision de ne
pas hypothéquer la fin des phases de
poule et donc de supprimer les fascine
et ça là pour le coup dans le dos dans
le côté passionné et le côté le côté
purement sportif est purement compétitif
là c'est une catastrophe parce que c'est
c'est comme vous le dites une l'essence
même du rugby amateur je parle même pas
pour les pros qui continue à jouer mais
pour le rugby amateur les phases finales
c'est là où tout se fait est là où les
souvenirs ce secret c'est là où vraiment
on parle d' aventure de potes
aventure humaine et à finir fini on va
dire fin avril début mai par les matches
de poule sans rien derrière ça va donner
de toute façon un gros gros sentiment
d'inachevé pour cette saison pour cette
deuxième saison particulière la coupe
des yvelines a également été supprimé
aussi pour le football
oui c'était un peu la seule solution est
la seule solution ce que vous le disiez
ça te va ça va devenir un vrai casse
tête pour trouver des dates de pour
jouer les matches d'automne voilà les
amateurs ont si des week-ends où ils
partent en vacances voilà ils ont une
vie aussi à côté à côté du sport donc
c'est de plus en plus compliqué la coupe
des yvelines wii qui qui va être
supprimé qui est aussi à côté du
championnat ça peut être à l'image de la
coupe de france on en a parlé dans ces
dans ses émissions une petite bouée
d'oxygène c'est une compétition en plus
qu'on jouait dans la saison compétition
différente une compétition différente
c'est 100% des yvelinois ont toujours
remporté cette coupe mais c'est fait
c'est bling c'est hyper fort cette
compétition mais c'est effectivement une
compétition différente on peut des fois
faire jouer les remplaçants qui n'ont
pas forcément l'occasion de montrer tout
l'étendue de leur talent en championnat
ça peut être l'occasion voilà deux on va
dire fortifiée l'effectif voilà de
concerner tout l'effectif mais ma
question à stéphane est-ce que c'est pas
trop rageant peut-être pour les amateurs
de
de ne pas jouer du coup de ne pas
s'entraîner alors qu'on voit les
professionnels continuer par exemple à
s'entraîner et à jouer
ça va donner un petit sentiment
d'injustice
pourquoi ils arrêteraient palais les
pros après c'est sûr bon ben c'est des
décisions qui sont prises et on peut
rien faire contre ça c'est l'argent qui
décide et en effet c'est pas les mêmes
c'est pas les mêmes enjeux et les enjeux
pour le sport professionnel sont
principalement financier donc à partir
de là en effet on a rendu le sport
professionnel possible mais il faut pas
faut pas l'oublier c'est que ils vivent
quand même dans des bulles pour pouvoir
se permettre de le faire
jean michel rossi pour le sport ce qui
est impossible pour le sport amateur
j'entendais hier d'un quotidien un
athlète basket l'élevage fournier voilà
qui disaient que je vous aime pas s'unir
orlando qui joue à orlando voilà et
qu'il disait que justement il était dans
une bulle
il avait pour pouvoir finir les phases
de jeu l'année dernière ils ont passé
deux mois à l'hôtel dans un indice mais
chez disney et pour que tout le monde
puisse finir de jouer donc c'est quand
même des conditions qui ne sont pas
possibles pour commun des mortels parce
que là psychologiquement c'est quand
même très très lourd avec des tests si
régulier pour les professionnels des
tests au co vide qui serait vraiment
impossible à mettre en place pour les à
m on va passer à la prochaine thématique
on va maintenant parler prend le grand
large dans cette page coup de projecteur
le départ du vendée globe 2020 sera
donné ce dimanche 8 novembre depuis les
sables d'olonne divinement participera à
cette édition louis burton originaire de
rambouillet et s'alignera pour la
troisième fois sur cette course mythique
grégorini est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter cette course justement faut-il
encore présenter le vendée globe cette
course à la voile la plus grande au tour
du monde ça se déroule tous les quatre
ans au départ à l'arrivée des sables
d'olonne est une course en solitaire
sans escale et sans assistance qui a une
un trajet de 44 1980 16,2 km c'est un
périple un véritable défi où les
skippers vont devoir descendre
l'atlantique traverser les océans indien
et pacifique remonter une nouvelle fois
de l'atlantique
avec trois passages principaux on peut
le dire le cap de bonne-espérance le cap
le wind et le cap horn au sud de
l'amérique du sud est les skippers sont
confrontés une mer déchaînée
un froid polaire et des passages pour le
moins sensible on pense forcément au
golfe de gascogne au poteau noir est les
quarantièmes rugissants et 50èmes
hurlants et aussi à de nombreuses
avaries duquel nombreux l abandon à
chaque édition moins en moins sur ses
derniers espoirs par louis burton on ne
l'espère pas pour louis burton est ce
qui a valu d'ailleurs au vendée globe ce
surnom l'everest des mers
sur les 167 concurrents huit éditions
seule 89 ont réussi à franchir la ligne
d'arrivée et 3 au même péri en mer une
course qui a consacré aussi de grands
marins des marins français quitteront
lamazou alain gautier vincent riou
françois gabart armel le cléac'h qui a
battu d'ailleurs lors de la dernière
édition le record de du vendée globe
un vendée globe qu'il a réalisés en 74
jours et pour cette neuvième édition ils
seront trente trois skippers à prendre
le départ
et depuis les sables d'olonne et ce sera
le 8 novembre vous êtes fan yang gériez
alors oui véritablement et papa
dernièrement c'est vraiment quelque
chose c'est un souvenir d'enfance et
c'est vrai que au début je me disais
mais c'est fou les mecs ils partent
trois mois tout seul sur un bateau et
j'ai eu en fait la chance de passer un
des vacances en bretagne et devoirs des
grands trimarans et parce que quand on
est à la télé on se rend pas compte de
la taille des des bateaux et donc de
pouvoir les voir en vrai on se rend
compte de delà du côté gigantesque de
l'objet et je me souviens je crois que
c'était la trinitaine que j'avais vu à
l'époque donc est déjà un petit bateau
par rapport à ce qu'il fait maintenant
mais c'était il ya plus de 20 ans et
donc j'avais visualiser un petit peu un
petit peu tout ça et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est cdc des choses qui
ne sont vraiment pas accessible à tout
le monde
la fouettent 1
faut pouvoir avoir accès à la voile et
c'est vrai que quand on se dit qu'un
rambolitains peut accéder à cela on se
demande comment parce que j'en avais
tanguy de lamotte également sur la
précédente édition et éric bellion de
versailles et voilà il ne reste plus
qu'un donc c'est vrai mais bon voilà
c'est génial et donc non pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui était juste impensable
inimaginable et par contre quand on s'y
intéresse un tout petit peu de voir les
parce que là c'est pareil c'est des
progrès techniques technologiques de
voir toutes les vitesses qui sont
capables d'atteindre et la progression
du temps de course parce que à l'époque
c'était trois mois maintenant on est sur
72 jours donc on avait je crois qu'on a
gagné presque une grosse vingtaine de
jours entre les premières éditions et
maintenant c'est juste énorme c'est
vraiment très voilà wells et ses courses
au grand large c'est quelque chose de et
puis et puis avec toute cette
dramaturgie aussi parce que voilà il ya
plein de choses autour de tout ça est
alors maintenant ça devient encore plus
intéressant grâce aux moyens techniques
on peut vivre la course de l'intérieur
il arrive nous envoyer des images très
régulièrement communiqué je pense qu'ils
étaient pas il est possible dans les
dents les premières éditions
moi c'est vraiment un truc que j'adore
j'ai presque regret que ce ne soit que
tous les quatre ans mais je le mets
méchant même que du monde finalement
donné de la voix la pompe pour moi c'est
vraiment parallèle avec les paris dakar
à l'époque où paris dakar portait
vraiment de paris etc ou petit quelque
chose que vous vivez que l'on vivait
pleinement
je le mets sur le même hmm hmm hmm
auteurs d'intensité j'adore ce château
est fun on a conservé les aventuriers
des temps modernes dans les skippers je
veux qu'une chose c'est vrai que cette
année j'avais cette année j'avais décidé
d'aller voir le départ avec mes enfants
parce que maintenant on n'a pas la bonne
année très belles images
du départ et j'avais envie de le vivre
bon bah ouais on irait en quatre ans
dans quatre ans stéphane de bizet très
rapidement aussi vous êtes fans
cherchent mais je vais vous poser la
même question juste après non même si je
trouve ça beau c'est pas mon nom c'est
pas mon truc c'est pas votre truc c'est
pas mon truc
pourquoi pierre chevalier bon après très
fan et je trouve que c'est laid les
greniers vraiment les dernières grandes
aventures sportives avec le rallye raid
comme comme l'a rappelé comme l'a
rappelé m
c'est les derniers les derniers vraiment
grand espace d'expression de ce que de
ce que peut faire l'homme et la femme
navigateur navigatrice en partant comme
ça en autonomie et seul seul pendant des
jours juste simplement à se mesurer avec
un outil phénoménal qui est
effectivement a bien évolué en termes de
conception mais à se mesurer à la nature
c'est juste c'est juste époustouflant
comme comme comme type de course comme
type de course et d'événements sportifs
en tout cas louis burton prendra donc le
départ à bord de son imoca bureau vallée
deux présentations de ce bateau par
louis burton bateau fait deux tonnes de
moins déjà donc il va à la base beaucoup
plus vite
il faudra que nos bateaux ils font entre
7 et 9 tonnes
et puis on assez folle donc ces espèces
de dell du sous marine qui permet au
bateau de se lever et du coup
d'accélérer d'aller beaucoup plus vite
qu'avant ça sera donc sa troisième
participation il a connu différents à
scénario dans sa carrière en 2012 il a
abandonné assez rapidement après avoir
été percuté par un chalutier en 2017 il
a par contre terminé à septième de la
compétition
louis burton nous présente ses objectifs
pour cette année la dernière fois 7e en
87 jours et mon bateau actuel qui avait
fait l'édition précédente il avait misé
74 journaux qu'elle ait mis treize jours
de moins donc bon c'est énorme
évidemment alors fonction des conditions
météo l'objectif ce serait de passer
sous la barre des 75 jours et ça on
n'est jamais sûr c'est la météo mais par
contre essayer de faire une place
mieux que la dernière fois donc ça veut
dire entre premier 6e la question sur
cette thématique est ce que c'est
l'année où jamais pour louis burton
oui ou non il a un super bateau il est
en forme
non non oui pour vous on fait un petit
duel entre vous grégory et pierre
cadoret vous pensez l'année où jamais je
ne sais pas est ce que ça sera sa
dernière participation ça ça reste à
démontrer à 35 ans a encore de la marge
mais tanguy de lamotte par exemple
arrêté à 40 ans il arrive à 40 ans alors
avec une aventure un petit peu
différente un tanguy de lamotte sur
initiative car vous en avez parlé
nombreuses reprises ici moi je pense que
l'année où jamais non en tout cas c'est
une année pour montrer qu'ils
progressent vous l'avez dit première
participation il a dû abandonner au bout
de cinq jours il a appris de ses échecs
7e place lors de la dernière édition
c'est une quand même une belle une belle
performance
moi je pense que cette année c'est
plutôt une année pour montrer qu'il a
progressé est ce que il gagnera alors je
ne sais pas il estime qu'il a ses
chances pour terminer entre la première
et la sixième place je sais pas si c'est
l'année ou jamais en tout cas lui l'a
dit je crois au cours de votre interview
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'avec ce
vendée globe un peu cadenassé où il est
dans sa bulle on parlait des bulles des
sportifs tout à l'heure par rapport aux
autres années où il était d'eric
directement au village de départ là ils
la passent en famille dans sa salle
s'est dégonflé calme du calme et il le
dit lui sa salle mais aussi dans de
bonnes conditions avant d'aborder cette
aventure marine donc l'année où jamais
non je pense pas me lance en solitaire
en mer donc l'année ou jamais france pas
mais une année de pour montrer qu'il
progresse pierre chevalier
j'avais l'année ou jamais parce que
justement c'est ce c'est ce contexte là
qui fait que kylie kylie a priori plus
compétitifs que les que les précédentes
éditions auxquelles il a participé
notamment par tout le travail qui a été
fait par ces par ses ingénieurs et ses
designers avec un avec un bateau qui est
encore plus compétitif et qui il là il
l'a montré la cité justement avec
quelques ajouts de 2,9 par rapport
l'ancien bateau banque populaire qui l'a
récupéré et lui c'est un navigateur
encore encore plus expérimentés viens
d'en parler là de son contexte de
préparation aussi qui a été justement
qu'elle était peut-être optimisé par par
le côté très calme et très très exemple
de stress de l'ue burton jeu mais je
mettrai donc je mettrais un billet là
dessus sur 7 sur cette année
particulièrement propice à performer
avec 2 mai deux bémols le premier c'est
que il y aura malheureusement pour cette
année comme pour beaucoup comme pour
tous les autres sports l'absence de
spectacle c'est à dire que le départ va
se prendre dans un anonymat
on va dire désertique et est assez assez
assez inédit pour cette course est pour
cette partie là et puis le deuxième
bémol
évidemment c'est que c'est pas la
technique ou c'est pas le talent du
navigateur qui va qui va faire le
l'essentiel du résultat c'est la nature
c'est à dire qu'en gros en fonction en
fonction des vents en fonction du hasard
de ce qui va pouvoir croiser sur sa
route pendant la course
ça peut basculer ou au contraire
confirmé justement que les planètes sont
alignées pour lui permettre de de
performer voire de gagner
stéphane de visa qui vous a convaincu
grégory pierre
alors pour vous étiez plus sur les
nouveaux jamais moi je n'étais pas là je
pensais au match de saint-etienne - yani
jarrier non y'en as raison je pense
qu'il ya la raison vient de jarrier mais
moi je pense pas que ce soit l'année où
j'avais pas su en effet comme vous dites
il est encore jeune il a largement le
temps dans dirt participé à sept est
encore jeune mais c'est dans une idée de
progression finalement et je rejoins
c'est un plan de carrière qui l'a mis en
place moi ce qui me gêne c'est que oui
il a le bateau qui a gagné 4 on est en
quatre ans je suis désolé mais les
autres ont progressé aussi je la fais il
a fait quand même à moi peut progresser
son accord
oui mais je vais prendre un exemple très
simple pour moi ce type de compétition
c'est de la formule 1 c'est à comparer à
la formule 1 vous prenez la voiture de
lewis hamilton et 4 ans et vous prenez
là les aventures de l'émission
aujourd'hui en quatre ans c'est aux
antipodes
donc je ne vois pas comment et donc on
parle pas de la même voiture et on parle
bien des mêmes pilotes je ne vois pas
comment une écurie avec avec un matériel
ya quatre ans ne puisse pas faire
progresser son matériel vous reprenez la
voiture de l'écurie ten vous n'êtes même
pas sûr de faire une feinte on est sûr
comprend pas les chronos que lewis
hamilton à l'époque à bahia dujarrier
vous partez sur l'idée que le skipper
n'existe pas non non non j'ai non j'ai
bien dit en plus que si je prends la
voiture de lewis hamilton d'il ya quatre
ans je ne ferais même pas les mêmes
chronos que lewis hamilton alors non il
a fait passer leur peut jouer également
heureusement bien sûr que le speaker
heureusement que les skippers à tout son
intérêt son importance voilà là je pense
juste que en effet il va faire une
progression par rapport à la par rapport
à il ya quatre ans mais il va encore
manquer une une marche il manque encore
un peu de budget pour pouvoir aller
aller chercher à aller chercher le pour
moi le podium
en effet 4 4 ou 5 ce serait ce serait
très très bien et c'est tout ce que je
lui souhaite
après bien sûr que de toute façon si
devant ça casse ça peut sourire
est ce que je me suis juste avant le 10
mai quatre ans entre la première entre
les deux premiers il était vraiment
vraiment ex-thomson si le gouvernement
fait un super bateau tout noir qui
aujourd'hui est siglé dur vallée mais
voilà il y avait là la grosse crainte
qu'ils avaient je me souviens c'était ça
ils espéraient qu'une chose c'était de
ne pas casser ça s'était joué 1
très car très faible entre les deux
entre les deux premiers j'ai pas réviser
avant de venir malheureusement mais
comme souvent leur seul vainqueur on
aimerait le voir avec un vendée globe
qui a retrouvé son public parce que
l'essence même aussi du vendée globe
c'est ce ce village départ cette fête un
mois avant le départ aux sables d'olonne
on sait qu'ils ne reprendraient pas une
victoire danser dans ses bagages
si ce qui ne serait pas heureux mais
nous on serait plus heureux s'il peut
avoir cette victoire avec un public
vraiment au rendez vous et je pense
qu'ils prendraient quand même mais il
faudrait quand même que sur le retour en
janvier et on prendra aussi en janvier
retour aujourd'hui on peut espérer que
y'a du monde à la rivière chevallier
c'est comme c'est comme si le psg avait
gagné la ligue des champions en huit
clos et après le faina legs il l'aurait
évidemment pris 7 10 des champions
sk pas quand même une preuve on le
disait une part de chance finalement
grégory peut-être une part de chance
français alors sur la sur sa première
participation louis burton s'est pas
trop les circonstances visiblement est
ce que c'est le chalutier qui l'a
percuté au lui qui a percuté le
chalutier avancer la nuit c'est un peu
compliqué ouais voilà après ça dépend
énormément de la météo ça a été rappelé
des fois on est au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment mais je pense que
l'essentiel aussi et effet par les
skippers il ya des impondérables ans
comme partout peut-être encore plus oui
c'est vrai à la voile avec avec cette
météo qui peut être capricieuse mais il
connaîtra les pièges à éviter un
peut-être pierre chevalier oui oui tout
à fait exquis là l'expérience pendant
deux parties six nations 3e un espace
liste et dieu sait que je sais que
vendée globe est une une course
exigeante et et la première je pense que
tous les skippers seront s'en
souviennent leur première et maintenant
aider et ne prévoit qu'une chose c'est
justement de pouvoir se réaligner être
compétitif avec un avec une forme
physique et une préparation mentale et
un bâton qui qu'ils soient au niveau
donc oui il sera il saura éviter éviter
la majeure partie des pièges en tout cas
on les souhaite bon courage pour cette
compétition passe maintenant à notre
page débats
[Musique]
dans cette page débat c'est votre
rubrique grégory à nous l'avons baptisé
l'envolée de grégory de quoi allez vous
nous parler dans ses 30 ans cette
envolée je vais vous parler de la figure
de proue d'un collectif celui qui doit
trancher qui fait de belles trouvailles
qu'ils se trompent aussi parfois
celui aussi qui est en première ligne
pour défendre ses joueurs à affronter la
presse après de mauvais résultats
supporter la la pression extérieure je
parle de l'entraîneur de l'entraîneur
exactement mais vous l'aviez à noter sur
votre papier et un peu il port dos est
l'entraîneur le costume de super héros
en lançant ce volontiers quand tout va
bien mais on le condamne aussi
malheureusement à la première occasion
quand les déconvenues se présente car ne
l'oublions pas l'entraîneur c'est un
humain avant tout même si on a tendance
à l'oublier quand on le voit haranguer
ses joueurs sur le côté du terrain et
l'entraîneur c'est aussi malheureusement
un simple fusible que l'on n'hésite pas
à faire sauter est le dernier exemple en
date dans les yvelines avec la s fois ci
c'est du football laurent fournier
remercié par son club il était lise
étaient les yvelinois lanterne rouge de
national 2 avec sept défaites et trois
nuls cette saison très compliqué pour
moi c'est très compliqué avec un dernier
revers face à sainte geneviève des bois
le 24 octobre dernier qui aura été
fatale à laurent fournier poissy se
sépare de son entraîneur
un an après avec un nom un peu plus d'un
an de collaboration n'avait rejoint
poissy en juin 2019 et on l'a appris 1
son remplaçant il ya quelques jours
c'est walid al choura non certes moins
connue mais qui a un profil qui connaît
très bien le championnat national 2
alors l'arrivée d'un nouveau coach
derrière produit souvent le célèbre choc
psychologique au moins sur le court
terme ce qui pourrait laisser croire que
l'entraîneur finalement c'est le seul
responsable des mauvais résultats mais
est ce réellement le cas ne
sous-estimons pas le rôle du président
qui doit donner aussi les moyens à son
coach de réussir lui aussi élu laisser
au cip est les mains libres pour agir
deux mauvaises relations un trop grand
interventionnisme la pression financière
aussi dans le sport professionnel
peuvent compromettre la réussite de
l'entraîneur et parlons des joueurs qui
sont aussi les premiers acteurs sur le
terrain d'un scénario écrit par le coach
ce qu'on appelle la tactique à
l'entraîneur doit être un manager qui
doit tirer le meilleur de son collectif
mais c'est aussi aux joueurs de tirer le
groupe et le coach dans un même sens
voilà dans une même direction c'est un
devoir ils doivent se battre sur le
terrain pour le club qu'ils représentent
mais bon difficile de renvoyer 22
joueurs quand les résultats ne sont pas
au rendez vous l'entraîneur reste la
seule variable d'ajustement mais est il
le seul responsable des mauvais
résultats
je n'en suis pas si sûr votre avis sur
cette envolée de grégory cette quatrième
envolée grégory est ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que vous êtes d'accord et grégory
ou pas le coach n'est pas qu'un simple
fusible si le coach est un fusible
maintenant je suis complètement d'accord
avec lui pour moi c'est pas lui qui est
sur le terrain c'est d'ailleurs quand on
voit la forme physique de laurent
fournier heureusement
c'est une blague faite c'est vrai que ma
carrière une très belle carrière
olala beaucoup grand respect complet
mais moi si je fais le parallèle avec ce
que je vis quand je suis sur le vélo le
coach peut me dire ce qu'il veut pendant
le pendant le brief pour pour un match
solide est ce un match de vitesse c'est
quelque chose qui qui dure très peu de
temps 12 secondes d'effort 10 secondes
d'effort pardon et parfois la course se
joue sur un manque d'attention et je
suis désolé à ce moment là mais c'est
pas le coach qui cas pas cas pas fait
attention
je me souviens avoir perdu un titre en
80 en 2017 pardon à los angeles
tous vos musiques j'étais très fort et
j'avais fait le deuxième chrono un
pouillème de celui qui a gagné mais
techniquement il n'avait plus les
meilleures techniques que moi il a été
plus malin et là je suis désolé le coach
ne pouvait rien faire c'était moi et moi
et je n'en ai jamais voulu à mon
entraîneur à l'époque je ne m'en suis
voulu qu'à moi même d'avoir d'avoir raté
cette eau que cette occasion là alors
bien sûr après ça permet de rebondir et
de d2 et puis 2 d'avancé deux ans après
deux degrés de devenir champion mais là
pour une équipe
je suis désolé le discours du président
il est simple c'est je ne pouvais pas
virer 22 joueurs donc ça veut bien dire
que il n'en veut pas à laurent fournier
sait pas on l'a eu au téléphone juste
avant le début de l'émission ce n'était
pas contre laurent fournier se lancer si
c'est pour créer une étincelle et donc
laurent fournier aujourd'hui sert de
fusible
c'est quand même moi je pense que c'est
dommage parce que quand on a un
quand on est athlète de cette envergure
qui vient vous coacher c'est un mec tu
as joué en ligue 1 qu'à jouer au psg
marseille car entraîner le psg je suis
désolé quand vous êtes un joueur de
nationale 2 vous devez vous sortir les
tripes pour pour quand quand vous n'avez
pas le droit de remettre en question la
parole de de cet homme c'est pas
possible il et il a toute la crédibilité
dont vous vous devez vous servir et
prendre ce que dit je te dis ce coach et
je suis donc après on n'a pas toutes les
tous les éléments on sait pas comment
comment ils vivent au quotidien
mais c'est vrai que il ya un truc c'est
pas normal qu'un coach est une personne
comme ça n'arrive pas à faire vivre un
club de national de pierre chevalier
je ferai un distinguo en mettant un
sport à part par rapport à tous les
autres c'est le football d'ailleurs dans
la présentation de grégory c'était c'est
le football qui a été pris en exemple
avec avec l'exemple de laurent fournier
je trouve que dans le football plus que
dans n'importe quel autre sport et
notamment chez les professionnels il ya
une pression du résultat qui est elle
est évidemment des enjeux financiers on
en parle suffisamment souvent sur ce
plateau les autres les enjeux sont tels
que on demande une obligation de
résultat dans les eaux sens propre du
terme à l'entraîneur qui en ce sens dans
le football me paraît être comme un
fusible régulier est quand même en
quatrième division à pierre chevalier
bien sûr et bien sûr je serai d'autre
part à l'aide aussi mais avec le rugby
un peu un plus haut niveau
c'est simplement l'impression et la
phrase du président de policiers a tout
résumé c'est hier gros c'est le nombre
par rapport à le
ce chef d'orchestre reste à savoir si
par exemple fournier avait bien toutes
les clés tous les moyens et eu
l'occasion de faire son équipe tel qu'il
le pensait ou si il a eu le vestiaire au
fur et à mesure contre lui et puis une
scoumoune qui fait qui fait qu'il a
plusieurs résultats
résultat en sa défaveur il n'a eu pour
précisions il n'a pas eu tous les
joueurs qui le désiraient il devait y
avoir normalement un ou deux joueurs qui
devait arriver en fin de mercato
ça ne s'est pas fait et ils en voulaient
peut-être un petit peu la direction peut
être donc c'est là c'est là où le ou la
question se pose est-ce qu'ils avaient
tous les moyens à ce qu'ils avaient les
clés pour pouvoir bien réussir son job
mais lorsque lorsque les résultats ne
sont pas là ils avaient ils avaient une
obligation de gagner de marquer six
points sur les deux dernières rencontres
est là et la défaite par rapport à
sainte geneviève des bois la plante est
la plante et même avant d'avoir commencé
en fait là dessus et c'est celle c'est
l'entraîneur qui sautent avant les 22
joueurs
si on peut faire un parallèle il ya il
ya eu très récemment une autre actualité
à plus haut niveau en top 14 dans le
dans le rugby avec le limogeage des deux
entraîneurs d'agen dû et su agen et là
c'est la question est presque la même
sauf qu'à aider elle est beaucoup moins
fréquent de rugby que dans le dans le
que dans le foot tu es c'est que
l'humain c'est à dire que le message
doit passer entre l'entraîneur de rugby
et ses joueurs et son groupe quel que
soit le niveau
mais je dirais que c'est surtout une
question d' une question de moyen de
clés et de et de poids justement sur les
décisions sportives et de gestion et de
management qu'à l'entraîneur ou pas et
qui fait qu'il est qu'il devient un
fusible un fusible automatique
bon là là maintenant sur lequel laurent
fournier avec cette défaite et quelques
nuls
de toute façon est en position de
lanterne rouge il n'y avait pas grand
chose à une suggestion également de
france dès l'entrée en lice de l'équipe
de poissy ça et puis quand on regarde la
carrière d'entraîneur de laurent
fournier il a une à une - belle carrière
d'entraîneur que deux joueurs est en
fait ce sont des ce sont des périodes
assez courte
quand il quand il a entraîné créteil
quand il a entraîné la réserve du psg
quand ils en quand il a entraîné
strasbourg
c'est une ou deux saisons max donc il ya
un truc qui cloche six dont deux
peut-être dans le message est là et la
fois ci s'est pas passé et dieu est là
aussi il a il avait le maire de poissy
est un est un ancien est un ancien de
canal est un ancien du football
le livre car le lit voilà et il connaît
très bien le football et je pense qu'il
y la connaissez très bien laurent
fournier et il a tenté ce qui pouvait
tenter il ya un moment où il faut il
faut créer justement l'électrochoc dont
parlait tant parler grégory à la fin de
son ne sont envolés stop pour vous
pierre chevalier
il fallait y mettre un stop il y avait
plus grand chose pour le sauver
je me demande si les joueurs n'ont pas
lâché ou d'un moment c'est clair parce
que sur les dernières rencontres
poissy était à la limite de gagner ou au
moins d'espérer un match nul ils
prennent un but à la dernière minute
c'est dans les dernières minutes
il a eu un objectif de ce petit point
qui n'a pas réalisé d'ailleurs je crois
que les seuls points qu'ils ont eue
c'est un match sur tapis vert qu'ils ont
gagné parce que l'équipe de granville
avait aligné un joueur qui était
suspendu je crois que c'est le seul
point que poissy a pour l'instant donc
effectivement stéphane debyser match nul
contre versailles également pour le
derby 1 0 0
voilà donc vous est déjà pris parti
il fallait qu'il parte cfa de bizet oui
c'est clair le message n'est pas passé
il n'a pas les moyens et il faut miser
maintenant sur l'électro choc
oui il fallait qu'il parte on suivra ça
avec attention en tout cas il ya un
nouvel entraîneur qui est qui arrivait
un grégory des jours et qui a plusieurs
saisons d'expérience au club de viry
châtillon essonne qui a été longtemps au
niveau cfa c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la la nationale 2 donc je le
disais tout à l'heure un nom certes
moins connue au niveau national que
laurent fournier où il serait quasiment
clinquant - claquant mais très connue
donc c'est un vrai choix du président
qui le connaissait depuis quelques
années qui a l'expérience vraiment de ce
championnat de nationale 2 avec de très
bons résultats pendant longtemps du côté
de viry-châtillon mensura ça avec
attention en tout cas on continue ceci
en parler sport part du cyclisme je vous
vois sourire
yann dujarrier nous vous l'annoncions la
semaine dernière l'information était
confirmée ce week-end la 21e et dernière
étape du tour de france 2000 21 partira
depuis chatou dans les yvelines le 18
juillet prochain
le peloton s'élancera de cette commune
de 31 mille habitants pour rejoindre les
champs-elysées au programme 112 km ou un
sprinteur devrait une nouvelle fois
s'imposer
on écoute la réaction de jean-michel
richefort vice président à la fédération
française de cyclisme
bush à tous est une ville sportive une
ville cycliste avec un très bon club le
team cycliste
de de chatou qui participent
régulièrement sur des épreuves
régionales et des épreuves nationales
non c'est un excellent choix et je pense
que nous aurons une belle dernière étape
avec une boucle qui passera bien sûr
dans les yvelines
et puis avec l'apothéose sur les champs
elysées vous êtes d'accord l'apothéose
sur les champs-elysées une superbe
dernière étape à chaque fois j'adore le
sprint des champs elysées pour une seule
raison c'est le sun ce prix c'est le
seul moment où on peut suivre les
coureurs comme si on était dans le
peloton en fait france télé comme la la
la la venue est très très large france
télé un petit couloir et il arrive à
mettre une claque d'une moto avec une
caméra c'est un peu seul et j'adore ça
donc pour moi et alors ça fait pas très
longtemps ça doit c'est depuis c'est
depuis que on a eu l'arrivée le soir
donc c'était pour le centenaire du tour
de france n'est pas très très longtemps
qu'on a qu'on a c'est ce plan caméra et
j'attends toujours ce dernier mot parce
que c'est vrai qu'on voit véritablement
on ne voit pas de la même manière que
quand on quand on est à la caméra en
face c'est pas du tout de même c'est un
zoom street
moi je le kiffe c'est pas forcément une
dernière étape s'est pas forcément à
part pour les sprinteurs je suis
largement to fuck lors on a parfois vu
le plus grand du peloton et changer son
vélo avec le plus petit donc d'un coup
dans l'autre sens on a ce spectacle on a
aussi vu lance armstrong avec une
perruque avec une camionnette une
bouteille d'eau une paye de chanter une
une coupe de champagne voilà en effet
c'est un peu le folklore mais c'est
comme ça surtout les grands tours c'est
pas c'est pas juste sur le shop tour de
france la dernière étape c'est vrai que
c'est c'est le plaisir c'est la parade
voilà c'est la parade je regrette juste
une chose on allume entre la jolie on a
eu confiance un tonneau rinne on à
chatou là ça fait quand même au moins
trois ans qu'on est sur le nord des
yvelines est allé dire à quel niveau
parce qu'on a eu on a eu rambouillet on
a eu à rambouillet mantes-la-jolie et
l'achat tout mon appel conflans sainte
honorine
on n'a pas eu un départ de conflans pas
encore d'accord confluence avec
paris-nice s'est pas réunie tarn et donc
voilà c'est vrai que là ça fait quand
même des départs qui sont un peu dans un
peu sur le nord de niort j'aimerais bien
revoir un départ de versailles a dit oui
c'était passé par la vallée de chevreuse
quand il était parti de rambouillet oui
bah oui mais en bout y est on est on est
sur le sur le sud non j'aime moi
j'aimerais j'aimerais revoir un beau
départ de versailles
c'était je me souviens c'était c'était
un beau c'est une des belles de belles
images encore bien sûr que bon les
passages par la veille cheuvreux son
sont toujours sympas et est obligatoire
quand quand le tour de france et est
donc dans le coin mais ouais je suis
seule chose ah ça fait ça fait deux ans
qu'on est con et un peu un peu trop dans
le nord est après mon premier tour de
france et que ce mois de juillet et on
est en vacances pour 2023 médiation ce
sera depuis le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça c'est sûr
c'est dans la convention c'est dans le
partenariat entre les yvelines
mais ça fait maintenant et ça ça fait
combien d'années que donc ça fait trois
ans voilà le tour de france voulait dire
trois ans pour le tour de france
ouais mais pour le paris nice a fait
onze ans d'accord avec a plus beaucoup
d'autres il ya comme ça part comme très
régulièrement des yvelines 3 en trois
ans grâce à un partenariat ça le restera
jusqu'en 2023 au minimum 1 grégory
lhomme ça peut ça peut se poursuivre ça
peut se poursuivre on parle de 2028 2029
peut-être alors la question sur ce thème
le cyclisme at il fait le tour dans les
yvelines
yanji j'arrive à le dire répondre non ça
c'est sûr stéphane pour vous non plus
stéphane pourquoi alors je laisse la vie
ou professionnels de ce côté là mais
s'il faut continuer à avoir le tour de
france le paris nice dans les yvelines
oui bien sûr vis et les yvelines sont à
l'honneur depuis pas mal d'années faut
continuer j'espère que pour château il y
aura plus les restrictions sanitaire
parce que ça va être magique ça va être
super beau et je crois que château avait
aussi donné
le départ du paris nice hosni paris-nice
également oui il ya quelques années je
crois que c'était en 2018 si je me
trompe pas alors oui donc ça avait été
apprécié par c'était sous la pluie on
voit les images j'espère qu'il y aura un
peu de soleil a par contre il ya eu mort
pas aussi j'aimerais bien que le tour de
france partent de maurepas aussi c'est
de chez vous en faites
super météo ce week-end là c'était je me
souviens c'était vraiment très très bien
pierre chevallier
alors pour vous non on n'a pas fait le
tour dans les yvelines
vous connaissez mon amour
incommensurable pour le cyclisme mais je
suis de ce côté là chauvin chauvin pour
les yvelines et pour avoir pas mal de
pas mal de copains qui roulent tous les
week-ends et toutes les semaines sur les
routes des yvelines s'est quasiment
quasiment sans limite et notamment que
ce soit que ce soit en termes de
dénivelé mais aussi paysage de paysages
et de jolis villages typiques qui font
que qui sont qui sont très très bien
mises en valeur par les équipes de
france télé et d'un vaisseau pour l'un
pour la partie tour de france donc je
pense qu'il ya un plan de petits moyens
et grands grands villages et villes et
villages qui rêverait d'accueillir
accueillir le départ du tour départ du
paris nice
de toute façon géographiquement on a
sept on a sept ce privilège d'être des
proches proche de paris centre et des
champs elysées ce qui fait que ça nous
place assez assez facilement et assez
facilement pour les départs pour le
départ de la dernière étape les
hauts-de-seine où le
ou l'essonne serait serait aussi en
piste mais peut-être un peu plus loin un
peu plus décalé et avec peut-être moins
de moins de moins de routes ou de ou
deux points de vue remarquables pour
pouvoir faire de belles images cette
dernière étape
le département a accueilli à 46 reprises
le tour de france en sept éditions
il a déjà remplacé idéalement placé 24 x
versailles et le premier départ enfin la
première fois que le peloton et
passerait passer par les imitent c'était
en 1903 il était passé par là et les
chevreuse justement yens dujarrier avec
une victoire 2 maurice garin ça vous
parle n'hésitez pas s'ils s'étaient
passés dans les yvelines
victor baltard d'état vient aussi d oui
voilà des scénarios un peu plus cruel
laurent fignon 89 qu'il dernière phrase
est dans une étape ebe noise a porté le
maillot jaune on connaît le scénario
cruel il avait maillot jaune au dernier
moment il a perdu pour quelques secondes
me seconde est remise les bois oui oui
beaucoup moins quelque part oui je m'en
suis remis c'était greg lemond c'est à
green fait partie de mes 2 courard
les premiers coureurs que j'ai un peu
idolâtrait on va dire voilà oui alors
moi je vais forcément dans la même
direction que mes camarades est d'autant
plus que tous les deux mickaël on est
journaliste dans un média local
désillusion qu'ont et on travaille et ça
nous fait parler en tout cas comme on
peut le voir très très rapidement
viennent du jard y est vous avez un
pronostic pour l'année prochaine on
sortira le dvd en en vainqueur du tour
pour les prochaines ou le lien on parle
d'égal à égal bernal vainqueur en 2019
au ghana en 2020 j'ai sept d'or grèvera
julian alaphilippe jeu
j'adorerais ge et attention il ya moins
de nice je suis pas pour moi julian
prend le maillot annuaire de bretagne ça
je le mets sur jeu mais je le mets sur
sur le tapis le tour va être beaucoup
moins montagneux un peu moins un peu
moins difficile il ya deux contre la
montre qui peuvent lui qui peuvent lui
être lui être favorable je suis je suis
très chauvin mais c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours du mal à donner 1
comment un couple non pendant pronostics
simplement un coureur qu'il soit par
l'ennemi chouchou et pour moi
aujourd'hui voilages pour moi julien mai
mais c'est un peu tôt pour lui c'est pas
encore danser encore notre objectif il a
il est encore d'autres choses à faire
avant dans le vélo mêlée c'est vrai que
ce serait je pense que aujourd'hui si on
a un coureur qui peut gagner tour de
france et par rapport à ce qu'il a fait
pas en 2020 mais vraiment en 2019
c'est c'est ça il faut savoir que son
tour de france 2020 il l'a fait en
préparation du championnat du monde 2000
2002 1020 qu'il a remporté il a couru
que la première semaine le reste il n'a
fait que de l'entraînement pour être
prêt pour le championnat du monde donc
on a compris à votre favori celle que
soit son statut lui ressortir à juillan
la passion ils ont très beau tour qui
fera un don qu'il fera un très beau tour
voilà oui j'ai un message de la part de
ma compagne parce que j'ai envie de
bouffer ce soir elles votent une thibaut
pinot ah ok bon ben on va voir on
sortira les liens comme je disais
précédemment
on va parler maintenant du golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines au mois
d'octobre la structure a fêté ses 30 ans
cette vidéo de la fédération française
de golf retrace l'histoire du site au
regard des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a vu tous ces moments magiques
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines va faire un petit tour de table
quel est votre moment préféré à grégory
moi je le disais un fois je suis pas
forcément un grand spécialiste de golf
mais en tant que journaliste on a
couvert tous les deux vous l'avez
couvert sur le terrain et moi en plateau
cette ryder cup 2018 qui a été un
événement exceptionnel en plus avec la
victoire de de la team europe ceux du
home hollywood tommy fleetwood et et à
francesco molinari donc la ryder cup
mais parce que je pars un grand
connaisseur moi je mets en avant ce cet
événement que j'ai d'abord des analyses
avaient adoré en termes d'ambiance était
superbe
il ya déjà riez pas pour moi le plus bel
événement ce sera les jo de 2024
voilà part à ce que parce que ben pour
moi je pense qu'alors après le prime du
golfe c'est vrai que les jo c'est quand
même pas encore c'est quand même en
dessous leur et le recul s'est passé pas
encore dans leur dans leur adn
c'est assez récent c'est assez récent de
la participation est donc mais je parle
dans l'ampleur de l'événement serge
pense que là on va vivre quelque chose
dans une 24 qui va être juste phénoménal
dans les yvelines
maintenant c'est vrai que cette ryder
cup qui a été en plus que moi j'avais
une grosse crainte sur l'organisation
mais qui a été organisée d'une manière
orchestrale magnifique voilà rien à dire
donc que je resterai aussi sur la razer
stéphane de viser c'est un moment qui
vous a marqué peut-être au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines très
rapidement la ryder cup oblige suite
leur avis et aussi de l'avis de yann je
crois que l'événement à venir seront
encore plus beau les géo et les
championnats du monde amateurs également
en 2022 pierre chevallier très
rapidement vous aussi je sais que c'est
difficile vous adorez le golf le golf
national à 3-3 moment la victoire de ré
mais la première victoire de remesy 2003
la victoire de thomas levet en 2011
ça c'était vraiment le franco français
le cocorico évidemment la ryder cup
la ryder cup est tous les moments
absolument phénoménaux et toute
l'organisation qui a tourné à tourner
autour et le scénario le scénario
heureux pour l'équipe
l'équipe européenne je rajouterais un
quatrième moment c'est la première fois
que j'ai joué l'albatros je me suis fait
défoncer je me suis fait hacher menu
c'est un tout qui restera à vie c'est un
super stadium 2-2 on n'a pas les vidéos
vous devriez pouvoir trouver ça sur
minitel sur 36 ont recherché ça c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation d'un américain en ce jour si
particulier pour les etats-unis une
citation du basketteur michael jordan il
faut se fixer des buts avant de pouvoir
les atteindre je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]